[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
53 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing all right.
I'm getting over
the flu little bit.
But otherwise, I seem to
be doing reasonably well.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty scared
about sharing a small recording
studio with someone
with the flu.
But other than that, very good.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
You did last week.
I wouldn't worry about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I should be fine.
I'm very excited about the
holidays, to be honest.
I'm excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
My indoctrination into
the American culture
continues as I partake
in Thanksgiving soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanksgiving,
Friendsgiving, and all the kind
of versions of turkey.
Yes.
Lots of food.
So today we have
someone from our team.
We have Aja Hammerly.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we're
going to be talking everything
Ruby, the beautiful
programming language, and how
you can do cool things
on the cloud with it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really cool.
We're going to see some really
awesome stuff that Google
Cloud has been doing with Ruby.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is one
of these episodes where
I'm excited about it because
I don't know much about Ruby.
Really?
I've written some
lines of code with Ruby
and had fun, but never
wrote anything real.
So I'm very excited about Aja
telling us a little bit more
about it.
MARK MANDEL: It's been
a while since I've
written Ruby, actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
then we have a question
of the week, which is about one
of our favorite, favorite old
time topics-- Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we're going to talk
about how you can manage
things if you want certain pods
or containers to run
on particular nodes
inside your cluster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Something that makes total
sense in a couple of cases
like you have one of
the machines is bigger,
or you have license
constrictions.
Constrictions-- is that a word?
MARK MANDEL: Constraints.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Restrictions or
constraints, not constrictions.
I just created the
word constrictions.
MARK MANDEL: I like that.
We should use that from now on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
But before that, we have
two cool things of the week.
And one of them I'm
so excited about it
because it is actually
something we've
been waiting for quite a while.
I know a lot of people that were
asking for it, many customers.
And we have it-- GPUs.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we're finally announcing
that we're going to
have GPUs in early 2017
available on Google Cloud.
It's been a long time coming.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
And it's going to be pretty
amazing, especially for you.
You do a lot of video games
and rendering, stuff like that.
it's going to be huge.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We've had rendering pipelines
on Google Cloud for a while,
but GPUs are definitely
going to help out, which
is going to be really awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
very excited about it,
and to see, basically,
all the cool things
that people are going to
be able to make with this.
MARK MANDEL: And
all the math people
who are going to have to
do very fast calculations.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
don't care about maths.
MARK MANDEL: Maths is fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm just kidding.
It's very important, too.
The second cool thing of the
week is about Google Cloud
joining the .NET Foundation.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think
this is super cool as well.
Really, I feel like Google
Cloud is really kind of-- I hate
to use the phrase,
doubling down--
is really focusing on .NET
and Windows as a really core
platform for Google Cloud.
I'm really excited about the
things going on in this space,
and I think this is just
another side of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was just a
couple of weeks ago that we had
the episode about .NET and
Windows and Google Cloud
Platform.
Maybe it's a good time
to listen to it again.
There's lots of work on that
side of the [INAUDIBLE],
so go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Well it sounds like it might be
time to go have a chat with Aja
about Ruby.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
So I am absolutely delighted to
have Aja Hammerly back with us
again in the podcast booth.
How are you doing today, Aja?
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm
having a good day.
I'm excited to come
talk to you guys.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Excellent.
In case people hadn't talked
to you either at conferences,
or events, or listened
to the podcast before,
do you want to tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you do?
AJA HAMMERLY: OK.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Google Cloud team.
And my two-- or my primary
focus is on DevOps, networking,
security operations,
monitoring, logging,
all that kind of stuff.
But my passion is Ruby.
And I've been part
of the Ruby community
for tenish years at this point.
And I'm really glad that
I get to talk a little bit
today about what Google's
doing with Ruby because that's
what I'm spending
some of my time on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And for those that
are interested
on your other passion, we
actually had you before.
We had you on-- I have it
right in front of me-- July 13.
So that was episode 34
talking about monitoring
and Stackdriver.
So if you're interested
about that, go check it out.
And today, instead, we're going
to be talking just Ruby, 100%.
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm so excited.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
So we're talking about
Ruby, the language.
I guess then why Ruby?
Why are we talking about this?
AJA HAMMERLY: So the Ruby
community is surprisingly big.
A lot of people don't
realize how big it is.
It's being taught in
a lot of boot camps,
and there's a lot of
relatively large websites
that are running it.
I think my favorite example
is GitHub, which most of us
use nearly every day.
It's got a fair amount
of Ruby internally.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
AJA HAMMERLY: And
it's a huge market.
There was a lot of stuff.
And we were trying to figure
out as part of Cloud Platform,
how can we support
our developers better?
And one of those ways is we
can support the languages
they're using and meeting
them where they're at.
And so I've been part
of our Cloud Ruby
effort over the last
couple of months
as we're trying to
beef up our libraries,
beef up our support for
Ruby, and make it a place
that Rubyists feel comfortable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what kind of things
that you've been working on.
AJA HAMMERLY: So, our two
big projects right now
are we're writing our
Google Cloud libraries,
being released as Ruby
Gems, and more and more
coming out nearly every
day, on a regular basis.
All this is being
done in the open.
It's all on GitHub under our
Google Cloud Platform Project.
And the other thing
we've been working on
is Ruby support in Rails
support for App Engine Flex.
We also support Sinatra,
the other big web
framework for Ruby.
And I'm really happy
with where that's at.
I actually got to participate in
a hackathon with it last week.
And I played a couple of my
personal projects, my side
projects, to the platform.
And it was awesome.
It was great that they
came up real quickly.
I got to see
everything in place.
Hooked it into Cloud SQL
with no issue at all,
just trying to get the right
IP address and the right files.
And it was really
awesome having something
that was that seamless and
that easy on our platform.
Because when I
started two years ago,
we didn't have a
ton of Ruby support.
And so seeing that
transformation over the time,
being able to talk
to my community
at events like RubyConf about
the cool stuff we're doing.
It's been really
exciting, and they're
excited to hear it, too.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I guess that
means, yeah, so you've
got the support there for the
frameworks and the tools that
come into the Ruby community
to be to deploy your stuff, as
well as all the SDKs, and
tools, and gems, I guess,
to interact with all our
backend services, like storage
and all our other things.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, I'm
actually really excited.
We're doing a bunch of
examples work right now
and flushing out the MLAPIs.
I did a cool talk at
RailsConf for using
the Vision API to do kind
of a "Where in the World
is Carmen Diego."
I think that might have been
your idea, Mark, that I stole.
MARK MANDEL: That is
a pretty awesome idea.
I have to be honest with you.
AJA HAMMERLY: So we
use the Vision API
to recognize landmarks.
And we used it to
recognize-- and we
did text-- speech and text
we translate with a sign that
was in Japanese.
We used it to recognize
various other things.
We did some geocoding based
on where landmarks were.
And we did it all in Ruby.
And it was really fun.
And the fact that I was able to
do that all in Ruby was great.
And the community
has been great.
We've been getting community
contributions, back
to our examples
repo, which I'm super
excited about because that means
the community wants to help us.
And pull requests welcome.
So it's been fantastic.
And we have support now
also for Visions Out.
We're working on Translate.
We have got support
for Speech coming out,
or in Flight at least.
And all this is
happening at GitHub.
You can easily see what's
working-- what's being
worked on at any given time.
And it's been fun.
And Ruby doesn't
have a ton of ML.
The Ruby community
and the ML community
don't overlap a huge
amount, and so being
able to bring these
tools in to these people
in a way that is really
simple to use has been great.
Because calling in
huge ML libraries,
like C libraries and stuff,
and then trying to link them
into Ruby is kind of a pain.
Whereas the cloud
ML libraries, it's
just an API call and something
that we already know.
And that's been great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So as you know,
I'm not a Rubyist.
So can you tell us
a little bit more
about how is the experience, if
you were a Ruby developer that
has done Ruby apps,
let's say web apps,
on other platforms
or maybe locally,
what is the experience of
moving that to the cloud?
AJA HAMMERLY: So this is
the part I like the best.
Once you figure out
the database piece,
and you can run your-- if
you're going to use Flex,
you can run your
database in Cloud SQL,
you can run it as a
separate instance,
you can use Datastore.
Once you figure out the
database piece-- and doing
that's actually pretty
straightforward-- you just
go in and edit the standard file
that you would edit to change
to your production
database configuration
or just edit your production
database configuration,
you type "gcloud app deploy."
And it goes.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
AJA HAMMERLY: And it
asks, is this a Ruby app?
And you say, yes, this
is, in fact, a Ruby app.
And it goes.
And the defaults work for
the vast, vast majority
of applications.
And the other nice thing is
that a lot of our libraries
have been written by hand.
And so there's a lot of stuff
that just feels natural.
My favorite example is
our BigQuery library.
So BigQuery is the
database product.
And if you go into co-create
a new table in BigQuery
using the Ruby
library, use a syntax
that is nearly identical
to the syntax you use
to write migrations in Rails.
It's the same kind
of block format.
And the first time I did it,
I'm like, wait, I know this.
It was that moment from
"Jurassic Park" again.
But we do that in other places.
The Vision API, one of
the kind of things in Ruby
is there's always more
than one way to do things.
It's kind of
anti-Python in that way.
Although the communities are
largely overlapping and syntax
looks similar a lot of the time.
And the Vision API has four
or five different methods
to send out a request, even
though there's only actually
one vision Endpoint on
the API on Google's side.
And that just feels natural
because I can ask it
for landmarks, or I
can ask it for faces,
or I can ask it for labels.
And it's sending a request.
It's the same request out, but
I can actually get the data
that I want in that situation.
So it's been fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If
I remember correctly,
you made a video
not that long ago
about how to make
BigQuery tables with Ruby.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
I've been working on
a new video series
as part of our Cloud
Minute that's using Ruby.
We did "Making a
BigQuery table."
We did "Uploading a
Picture to Cloud Storage."
And I used a lovely
picture of a mountain goat
from a hike I took recently.
It was fantastic.
And we've also been doing
some videos with some
of the community libraries.
Fog is the multi-cloud
provisioning and deployment
type library for Ruby.
It supports AWS.
It supports Rackspace.
It supports a lot of stuff.
And there's several
folks at Google now
who are working on
improving fog-google.
And I've been doing demos
with fog-google showing how
you can use the tools that
you're probably already using
to interact with our
platform, in addition
to the platforms
you might be using
or the stuff you might
be more familiar with.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I think that there's a question.
We went over it real quick.
You mentioned the
Datastore or Cloud SQL.
In case people don't know,
what is the difference?
Could we talk a
little bit about,
in terms of a Rubyist,
what is Datastore?
AJA HAMMERLY: So Datastore is
our NoSQL database in Google,
at Google.
And to be honest, I
don't know a ton of folks
who are using NoSQL with Rails.
I'm sure there are some.
In fact, we talked about that a
couple of minutes ago before we
started.
Several of us have done
that at various points.
But a Cloud SQL is
our hosted MySQL,
and it's just a
drop-in replacement.
You can use the exact same
MySQL gem that you use.
And you just point it
at the correct host IP
that we give you,
and it just works.
It's great.
And then if you want, a lot
of Rubyists like PostgreSQL.
I like PostgreSQL.
And if you want
to run PostgreSQL,
you can totally run PostgreSQL
on a Google Compute Engine
instance and manage your
own PostgreSQL instance,
if you want.
MARK MANDEL: I know we also
have Deployment Manager
through the Cloud Launcher.
You can deploy
PostgreSQL that way,
and it works out quite nicely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you basically-- you just
click once, deploy it, that's
it.
MARK MANDEL: That's it.
Nice.
So I know you do a lot of
stuff on the monitoring side.
Are there any hooks there
for monitoring Rails apps
or Ruby apps as well?
AJA HAMMERLY: So
we've got a team.
We've actually built a really
fun Ruby team in Seattle.
There's four or five
of us who work on Ruby
on a regular basis,
including several doves who
are working full-time now.
And one of the
things they're doing
is they're making
Stackdriver integration
libraries for Rails and Ruby.
I believe the login
library went out last week,
and the rest of them
are in progress.
And this is all, again, on
GitHub under the Google Cloud
Platform "G Cloud Ruby Project."
So you can see our progress.
You can see what issues
have been entered.
Obviously, we're going
to have some integrations
with other parts of the system,
GRPC libraries, and things
like that.
And so if there's particular
issues you're running into,
you can see if someone
else has reported it,
and how close we
are to fixing it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you
mentioned a little bit
about the things that
you've been working on
and what's coming up real soon.
What else is coming up?
What are you excited about
and that other Rubyists might
be excited about it on
Google Cloud Platform.
AJA HAMMERLY: So I'm actually
really excited about the fact
that we just recently had
the App Engine Flex beta 2,
and that App Engine Flex is
getting very, very stable
and starting to
look really good.
In Ruby, we have some
platform-as-a-service options,
but always having more is great.
As I say pretty
frequently when people
ask me to compare
various providers,
they're all different, but
competition helps everyone.
Because everyone's
pushing the envelope,
making the experience
better, and setting
a higher bar for
how developers get
to interact with these tools.
So I'm really excited
about App Engine Flex.
I'm also excited
that we're doing
some automatic code-generated
libraries for some of the APIs
that we haven't gotten around
to yet-- haven't gotten around
to doing the hand-coding on.
And those are happening--
I'm happy those are happening
because that means there's
more and more stuff
that I can just
interact with from Ruby.
I don't have to worry
about creating my own HTTP
request to hit the REST
endpoints, for example.
And I'm also just
happy that we're
coming out with more examples.
The team here is working
on lots of cool tutorials
on how to hook pieces together.
We're doing more videos.
We're doing blog posts.
We had a post on the open
source blog earlier this year.
And we're just trying to
get more stuff out there
to get part of the community.
And I'm really excited
that as a Rubyist,
a longtime Rubyist, that I
can say, hey check it out.
We've got stuff for you.
And there's stuff coming
from the community.
A couple of months ago,
there was an announcement
that someone had done
Ruby TensorFlow bindings.
And that came completely
from the community,
and I was super
excited about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is really cool.
AJA HAMMERLY: And I love
my community so much,
that I'm glad there's
stuff that they can use.
I'm like, we have all these cool
things, and you can use them.
It's fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: That's great.
You touched on, I think,
an interesting point there.
You're talking about
comparing providers.
I think the elephant
in the room a little,
the traditional--
I guess that might
be the right word-- people
tend to go towards Heroku.
Why might they be interested in
going to Google Cloud Platform
instead?
AJA HAMMERLY: So yeah, I
don't know if traditional
is the right thing.
But I work with a lot
of boot camp students,
and a lot of them learn
Rails because it's
the
convention-over-configuration
thing makes it easy
to learn for people
who don't have a
ton of experience
because there is a right way.
And they often use Heroku
for their early deployments.
So Heroku's great.
I've got a lot of
friends who work there.
It's got a lot of
great things about it.
I think that our App Engine
Flex and Heroku are slightly
different in some ways.
App Engine Flex gives you a
lot of options about database
layer, for example.
You have to pick-- you have
to pick a database layer.
And it also is based
on container image.
So you can actually
see the whole way down.
The container image is
available to the public.
You can see the whole way
down what we're doing.
Now Heroku's got a
lot of integrations.
They've been around
for a long time.
So there's a lot of people
who like their integrations.
But we also have integrations
with things like Stackdriver
to do the monitoring.
And we have integrations
with our MLAPIs.
We have integrations
with Datastore,
for example, if you
want a NoSQL solution.
And so I think it's-- I always
say this when people ask me
to compare providers.
I get asked a lot.
It really depends on
your use case and stuff,
but you can generally
figure it out.
Also our pricing
model is different,
and so that's another thing
that people should consider,
is looking at how
the pricing differs
based on what they think
their use case is going to be.
MARK MANDEL: I know
you were talking about,
when we were talking before
we started recording, about
basically the flexibility
that having everything running
on Docker containers
also gives you.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, so
it's the other thing
is I like to talk about.
And I have a talk half-written
but haven't gotten an accepted
anywhere.
It's "Growing Your Application
on Google Cloud Platform."
And you start with a bare
minimum viable deployment.
You do it on Flex
because it's easy,
and you can iterate as
quickly as you need to.
And you don't have to
worry about the scaling
because we'll take
care of that for you.
But then you realize
you want to move
to a microservices
architecture, or perhaps you
want to do something
interesting with your database,
and so you need to
move part of it off.
And so perhaps you
move parts of it
to Kubernetes because you have
the container image there,
and you can take it,
and you can strip out
the stuff you don't want
from our base container image
and then build your own.
Or you can look at how we
did it and build your own
based on that.
And then eventually,
maybe, there's
pieces that you just really
need to do on a plain old VM.
Maybe you're doing some
crazy image processing,
or video transcoding,
or something else
that's super compute intensive.
And it just makes more sense
cost-wise or performance-wise
for you to do it straight
up on Google Compute Engine.
And since you're
already on our platform,
your data's already there,
you've got the project set up,
you've got the
permissions set up,
it's really easy to grow
as your application grows
on our platform in
whatever way you need to.
And I think that's a
huge advantage of using
a platform like ours where
there's so many products
and so many ways to do things,
is that we can meet you
or you're at, wherever you
are in your product lifecycle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we
interviewed, some time ago,
Russel Smith from
Rainforest QA, and I
think there was this
interesting thing.
So Rainforest QA runs a
lot of things on Heroku.
But they also access BigQuery
and other technologies
that are on Google Cloud.
I think that that's also
pretty interesting things.
Even if you are
running on Heroku,
can you use things like,
I don't know, Stackdriver?
AJA HAMMERLY: Stackdriver
doesn't necessarily
make as much sense because
Heroku's a managed solution,
but you could definitely
use our MLAPIs very easily.
BigQuery is actually
really popular.
It's one of the
things that I think
got the fastest adoption
in the Ruby community.
And I know a number
of Ruby companies
that run Rails
that use BigQuery.
And you can totally
use that from anywhere.
You just have to
put your data in it.
And streaming it, it's a gem.
You install it
like any other gem.
You create the object,
and you send stuff to it.
It's fantastic.
It's two or three lines of code.
I love simple.
I love easy.
And so, yeah, even if you're
running in another place,
you can still use our tools
where they make sense.
If you're running
on AWS, you can
use all the Stackdriver
tools because Stackdriver's
across cloud.
And use the pieces
that make sense.
We've got a huge platform.
Find the pieces that make sense
for you based on your workload.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And where's the best
place to find the information
about all of this?
AJA HAMMERLY: So from the Ruby
side, cloud.google.com/ruby.
We have a landing page.
We've got tutorials, kickstarts,
links to the libraries,
including links to our open
source libraries there.
And that's a great place to go.
You can also go to the
general cloud page just
to find out about our products.
And since I know
the Ruby community
and the DevOps
community actually
have a fairly large
overlap, you can also
go to some of our
monitoring and logging pages
to find out about
DevOps community.
And the reason for that overlap,
for people who don't know,
is that Puppet and Chef are
written-- their DSL's on top
of Ruby, and so
there's a lot of folks
who worked on those
tools, or have contributed
to those tools, who
are also Rubyists.
MARK MANDEL: We do also have
a Ruby channel in the Google
Cloud Platform slack community.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yes we do.
And some of the developers
who work on our libraries
monitor it.
I was actually
checking it today,
and Mike was answering
questions someone had.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Now I know, also, you just
came back from RubyConf.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah I did.
RubyConf this year
was last week.
And it was really good.
It's one of my
favorite conferences.
And one of the
most exciting parts
was hearing Matz, the
creator of Ruby, speak.
And he was talking
about how Ruby
is becoming a mature language.
I mean, I got involved back
when it was, I think, Ruby 1.8.
And I've been through 1.9, and
we're on to 2.3 at this point.
And the planning now is
going on for Ruby 3.0.
And there's a lot
of talk about how
to support concurrency well.
There's a lot of talk about
improving performance, making
Ruby three times faster.
And I'm glad that those
conversations are happening.
And they're raising some
interesting questions
about language design.
Because one of Ruby's guiding
principles has always been,
it needs to be easy and
delightful for the programmer.
But that means there's
some stuff that
maybe isn't so
easy or delightful
for the actual computer.
For example, all
the metaprogramming
that's really easy
to do in Ruby,
I was talking to someone
today about the fact
that in Rails you might
be debugging methods
that don't exist
on in the source
because they're dynamically
created at runtime.
And that makes some
things very hard.
And so talking about that.
And I'm really excited
where that's going.
I'm also-- it's also excited
to see just who was there.
It was a lot of
folks there talking
about application
monitoring, about hosting,
a lot of interesting
things happening.
There was a great talk on
logic programming in Ruby.
Some fantastic talks about
nurturing open source
communities.
And I helped out with
the Ruby and hardware
track, which was just super
cool, lots of cool IoT stuff,
including some stuff
related to our machine
learning platform where they
were doing voice recognition,
and processing, and vision.
So a little girl and her dad--
Cora Clarke and Jason Clarke--
we did a presentation where they
had created a chicken detector
for their chicken coop
using a variety of pieces.
And it took a picture
every two minutes
so they can figure out which of
their chickens were laying eggs
and which of their
chickens were not.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That is awesome.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
And all that stuff, all these
places, all these IoT projects
and stuff are also places
that some of our libraries
could come into play depending
on what you need to do.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so we
are wrapping up here.
We were running out of
time just a little bit.
Is there anything we
haven't mentioned,
or anything you want to plug,
or event you're going to be at,
or anything really
super cool and exciting
you want to mention that we
haven't been the chance to?
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh, I think
I've mentioned all the really
super cool and exciting stuff.
But if there any Rubyists out
there listening to the podcast,
if you're going
to be a RailsConf,
I promise we will be there.
We were there last year.
We had a great time.
We're going to be
coming back next year,
and you should totally
come up and say hi to us.
And if you ever
see me at an event,
I will give you a
dinosaur sticker.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
I got a dinosaur sticker.
It is pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
They're pretty awesome.
I've got to say.
MARK MANDEL: All right, great.
Aja, thank you so
much for joining us.
We really appreciate you
coming and spending time
with us in this wonderful
gray room of podcastness.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yep, thanks so much.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thank
you guys for having me.
This is always fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So thanks so much
to Aja for taking the time
to talk to us about Ruby
and all the cool things
that are happening
about the language and
the open source community
on Google Cloud Platform.
And now we are going to
talk about Kubernetes.
We have our request of the week.
OK, so imagine I have a
heterogeneous cluster,
so not all dimensions
are exactly the same.
Not all the nodes
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And let's
say that, for instance,
some of the nodes have
SSD and the others do not.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I want
to run some of the containers
that require, or that run
better, let's say, on SSDs.
So you want to say, hey,
my cluster is very big
and have a lot of those nodes,
but whenever it is possible,
run these kind of pods
on these kind of nodes.
MARK MANDEL: So something
that's very Disk I/O heavy,
maybe is doing some
data processing,
maybe you're running a
database, something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's imagine that you
have a GPUs, for instance.
You have GPUs, and you
want to do some rendering,
so you want to make sure that
the container is running--
rendering run on
a node with a GPU.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How would
you do that with Kubernetes?
MARK MANDEL: So
that's pretty cool.
So if anyone's done
anything with Kubernetes,
you're probably
familiar with how
pods have labels and services
built on top of those to say,
OK, give me a selector that I'm
going to-- so with a service,
I'm going to have a
selector that says,
I want to expose all the pods
that have these labels, right?
So you've got these
arbitrary key value pairs
that you can attach.
So Kubernetes kind of extends
that whole idea of key value
pairs with labels, but rather
than having them on the pods,
you're able to add
labels to nodes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
MARK MANDEL: So you could
have type GPU or type SSD
on nodes within your cluster.
And you can add
those as you see fit.
What's neat, then, is
you have this thing
where you can have a node
selector in part of your pod
specification, where you do your
deployment or your replica set.
And you can add a
node selector that
says, hey, I want these only
to run on these nodes that
have these key value pairs,
these labels, till you
have a selector.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I'm looking at the
documentation now.
It actually looks pretty simple.
It's basically saying,
I just want these.
So it really, in the metadata of
the pod, when you're describing
it, where you're going
to say something like,
I want the node
affinity is going
to be something like, run
this on something that
has these values.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So in
our case, in our node
that has one of the labels
is something like GPU.
MARK MANDEL: GPU,
something like that.
You said an interesting
word as well.
The basic version of node
selector is very simple.
It's just this
combination of labels.
And it's very simple.
It's just an or-- it's
just an and Boolean.
But there is an alpha
feature of affinity,
which you said before, and also
anti-affinity, which gives you
a lot more control and a lot
more complex label selection
capabilities as well.
So you can do affinity, like
this running on these machines.
You can do preferred
affinity, like it
would be really great if it did,
but if it doesn't, that's fine.
And then you can do the
anti version of that too.
So I don't want
these running here.
Don't put on these machines.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Or I'd rather not
have [INAUDIBLE]
on these machines,
but if there's any
other choice-- whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
So that's an alpha feature.
It's coming down the pipeline.
But it looks like, yeah,
you've got a lot of control,
especially if you're running
heterogeneous clusters.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Well, I think that
answers the question.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So why don't
we talk real quick about what
are you going to be up to?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
not going anywhere.
So yeah, Thanksgiving,
that's coming up.
So we have some time off.
We've got our team off-site.
So, yeah, things are
ramping down for December.
Just writing some content,
and playing with some code,
and building some fun
things that I'll probably
talk about a little bit later.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And yourself?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well, I was planning
on working on JustForFunc,
but both of my laptops
died yesterday.
Yeah.
So I'm trying to fix that.
And in the meanwhile, I'm
enjoying some hobbies.
So yeah, I'm very excited
about our off-site
in two weeks in Los Angeles.
I don't know if we're
going to-- maybe we should
do an episode about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We'll do some recordings.
We'll see are they come out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, thank you so
much for joining me,
yet again, for a wonderful
episode, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
And see you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]